D
THERE TO EXPLORE THE CITY'S RICH
HISTORY.
LEARN MORE ABOUT IT ALL WEEKEND
ON AMERICAN HISTORY TV.
[GUNFIRE]
>> BRINGING THESE TANKS AND
STUFF AROUND HERE?
I TELL YOU WHAT, NO ONE IS GOING
TO HURT ME OR MY FAMILY.
YOU COULD HAVE ARRESTED ME GOING
TO TOWN, GOING TO WALMART.
WACO IS GOING TO BEAR WITNESS
AGAINST THE ATF.
NEVER WHAT I APPRECIATE SOMEONE
COMING HERE WITH HELICOPTERS AND
ALL OF THAT.
I WILL MEET YOU AT THE DOORSTEP
ANY DAY.
TO KEEP PLAYING THAT GAME?
I AM TALKING TO YOU.
SOMEONE IS GOING TO GET HURT.
>> INDIVIDUALS INSIDE THE BRANCH
DAVIDIAN COMPOUND, SUBMIT TO THE
PROPER AUTHORITY.
>> IN 1992 THE BUREAU OF
ALCOHOL, VACCO, AND FIREARMS,
BEGAN INVESTIGATING THE BRANCH
DAVIDIANS.
IT WAS BELIEVED THAT THEY WERE
MAKING ILLEGAL MODIFICATIONS TO
FIREARMS AND STOCKPILING
WEAPONS.
THERE HAD ALSO BEEN ALLEGATIONS
OF CHILD ABUSE WROUGHT AGAINST
THE GROUP'S LEADER.
THEY ATTEMPTED TO EXECUTE A
SEARCH WARRANT ON SUNDAY
MORNING, FEBRUARY 28, 1993.
A GUN BATTLE BROKE OUT BETWEEN
AGENTS AND MEMBERS INSIDE.
FOR AGENTS WERE KILLED DURING
THE SHOOTOUT.
ANOTHER 16 WERE INJURED.
FIVE WERE ALSO KILLED AND DAVID
CARESS WAS WOUNDED.
WHAT FOLLOWED WAS A 51 DAY
STANDOFF BETWEEN FEDERAL AGENTS
AND THE DAVIDIANS.
IT ENDED ON APRIL 19, 1993, WHEN
THE APP EI UNDER ORDERS FROM
JANET RENO TRIED TO GAS MEMBERS
OUT OF THE BUILDING.
A FIRE BROKE OUT AND SPREAD
THROUGHOUT, KILLING 76 PEOPLE
INSIDE, INCLUDING DAVID CARESS.
>> THE BEGINNINGS WERE WITH A
FELLOW BY THE NAME OF VICTOR
HOLLIS.
HE WAS BULGARIAN.
THEREFORE HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
ORTHODOX CHURCH.
HE EMIGRATED TO ILLINOIS AND
THERE HE VISITED A SERVICE OF
THE SEVENTH-DAY ADVENTIST CHURCH
, WHICH EMPHASIZED THEIR BASIC
IDEAS AS A RETURN TO CHRIST, THE
ADVENT OF THE SECOND COMING OF
CHRIST.
HE WAS CONVINCED WHETHER
TEACHINGS.
HE LOST HIS ORIGINAL
DENOMINATION AND BECAME A
SEVENTH-DAY ADVENTIST.
AND THEN HE BEGAN TO WRITE HIS
OWN LITERATURE AND HE BEGAN TO
CRITIQUE THE CURRENT SEVENTH-DAY
ADVENTIST CHURCH, THINKING THAT
THEY WERE NOT REALLY CONFORMING
TO THE TEACHINGS OF THE CHURCH,
THEN THEY HAD RELAXED A LOT,
THAT HE WANTED TO REFORM THE
CHURCH.
SO, IN THE END THE CHURCH
REJECTED HIS PROPOSALS FOR
REFORM AND BASICALLY JUST KICKED
HIM OUT OF THE CHURCH.
HE STARTED LOOKING FOR ANOTHER
PLACE TO GO.
FINALLY DECIDING ON THIS AREA
NEAR WACO, TEXAS.
SEEN AS A DIVINE FIGURE, LIKE AN
ALLY JOE OR JOHN THE BAPTIST,
ANNOUNCING THE COMING OF THE NEW
KING.
IN THIS TRADITION, YOU HAVE THE
NOTION OF THE IMPORTANCE NOT
ONLY OF SCRIPTURE AS AN
AUTHORITY, BUT A PROPHET
RECOGNIZING WHAT A PROPHET CAN
DO FOR THE COMMUNITY.
HIS IDEA WAS THAT IT WAS LIKE
TAKING A SCROLL AND FINDING NEW
INFORMATION THAT YOU CAN READ AS
YOU GO ALONG.
HE WOULD SAY HE WAS GIVING NEW
INSIGHTS TO YOU.
THIS IS WHY OTHER PEOPLE
FOLLOWED HIM.
AND 55 A FELLOW WHO HAD BEEN
FAMILIAR WITH THESE TEACHINGS,
WHO HAD BEEN WITH THEM FROM TIME
TO TIME, HE RETURNED AND SAID
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR A SIGN AND I
AM THE SIGN.
I HAVE YET MORE INFORMATION FOR
YOU.
HIS IDEA WAS TO CALL THIS NEW
MOVEMENT THE BRANCH.
THE NAME HAD BEEN REVEALED TO
HIM.
THIS IS WHERE WE GET BRANCH
DAVIDIANS.
HE LED UNTIL 78.
MEANWHILE HIS WIFE, LOIS, ALSO
HAD A SPECIAL TEACHING.
WHEN HER HUSBAND DIED, THE
FOLLOWERS JUST MOVED TO LEAVE
THEM.
AND THEN SHE LIVED ANOTHER SIX
TO EIGHT YEARS AFTER THAT.
AND SHE HAD SOME INFLUENCE AND
SO 86, WHEN SHE DIED.
BUT WHEN HOWL APPEARED ON THE
SCENE IN 1981, VERY SOON THE
PEOPLE BEGAN TO LOOK TO HIM.
HE WAS CONSIDERED A LEADER OF
THE MOVEMENT BY 83, 84.
EVEN BEFORE SHE WAS OUT OF THE
PICTURE THE PEOPLE BEGAN TO BE
DRAWN TO HIM BY VIRTUE OF HIS
ABILITY TO QUOTE THE BIBLE,
STRING PASSAGES TOGETHER.
CONSIDER HIMSELF A SECOND
MESSIAH, THE LAMB OF GOD,
LANGUAGE SUCH AS THAT.
>> MAYBE GOD IS THE ONE THAT HAS
INVITED A GOOD MAN.
THE THINGS HE HAS MADE.
>> DAVID CARESS CAME HERE CAME
HERE IN 1981.
HE STARTED BASICALLY SAYING THAT
HE HAD A MESSAGE.
HE STUDIED WITH THEM.
IT DEVELOPED INTO A POINT WHERE
LOIS CALLED US ALL IN 1984 TO
COME TO MOUNT CARAMEL AND TO
LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD TO SAY AT
THE TIME.
TO SEE IF HE WAS GOING TO BE THE
NEXT SPIRITUAL LEADER.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT IT COMING FROM
THE EAST.
A PERSON WHOSE NAME IS CARESSH,
ACCORDING TO SCRIPTURE.
A PERSIAN KING.
THE MYSTERIES OF THE ANCIENT
SIRENS, AND 45, HAD A SURNAME IT
MEANT WORD OF GOD.
YOU HAD TO LOOK AT A LOT OF
THINGS TO CATCH THE PICTURE.
>> HE BELIEVED HE CAME TO BRING
JUDGMENT ON THE CHURCH.
WHICH HE DID.
WE HAD TO JUDGE BETWEEN TRUTH
AND ERROR AND WHETHER WE SHOULD
FOLLOW HAMMER THE HOLY SPIRIT.
UNFORTUNATELY WAS PROPHESIES
THAT THE IT WOULD HAPPEN.
MEANING THAT THE LEADERS, THE
ELDERS THAT REPRESENTED THE
CHURCH WOULD HAVE TO GO ALONG
WITH HIM.
AND THEY DID.
THEY EVEN REJECTED LOIS AS THE
SPIRITUAL LEADER.
SHE DIED TWO YEARS LATER.
IT ALLOWED HIM TO REALLY TAKE
HOLD.
>> IT IS NOT AGAINST THE LAW TO
BUY FIREARMS OR ANYTHING THAT
THEY SELL AT THE GUN SHOW.
WHEN THIS IS ALL RESOLVED, YOU
KNOW, IT IS LEGAL.
THE ACCUSATION IS NOT.
>> THE QUESTION OF A COLLECTION
OF FIREARMS THERE IS MUCH
DEBATED.
THAT WAS THE BASIS OF
UNDERSTANDING FOR THE ARREST AND
SO FORTH.
TO READ MANY OF THE LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS, THEY INSISTED THEY
DID NOT KNOW IT WAS GOING ON OR
THAT WHAT LITTLE THEY DID NOW
THEY SAID IT WAS BEING USED AS A
WAY TO MAKE MONEY, TO GO TO A
GUN SHOW AND SELL THESE FOR A
PROPHET.
SO, USING THAT AS A METHOD
CAUSED SOME EYEBROWS TO BE
RAISED.
ACYCLIC HASIDISM TRADITIONS
OF CONSCIENTIOUS OBJECTION THAT
-- BASICALLY PACIFISM OR
TRADITIONS OF CONSCIENTIOUS
OBJECTION TO THAT, THEY WERE NOT
THERE TO DO BATTLE WITH ANYONE
OR SO FORTH.
THAT WAS THE DIFFERENCE.
AND THEN HIS THEOLOGY, HE ARGUED
THAT HE WAS SUPPOSED TO SIRE THE
24 ELDERS MENTIONED IN THE BOOK
OF REVELATIONS AT THE LAST
JUDGMENT.
TO DO THAT, HE SAID HE WOULD
COHABIT WITH LIVES OF THE MEN --
WIVES OF THE MEN WHO WERE THERE,
THE MARRIED COUPLES.
THIS WAS A HUGE TRANSITION, AS
WELL.
>> THE QUESTION IS, WHAT AM I
DOING?
WHAT AM I DOING WITH ALL OF
THESE CHILDREN?
GOD IS GOD.
IT SAYS, IN GOD WE TRUST ON OUR
CURRENCY.
THESE CHILDREN THAT I HAVE FOR A
REASON, AND UNLESS WE REALLY
HAVE THE EARS AND EYES TO OPEN
OURSELVES UP TO REALLY READ THE
SCRIPTURES AND UNDERSTAND THE
SEVEN SEALS, THE QUESTIONS WOULD
SEEM ALMOST FOOLISH.
>> THERE AGAIN, THIS WOULD BE
CONTRARY -- CONTRARY TO WHAT
VICTOR HOT OF SAID IN TERMS OF,
WE WANT TO LIVE HOLY LIVES, AND
WE WANT TO BE SEPARATE FROM THE
WORLD.
THIS LOOKS LIKE REALLY A SEA
CHANGE IN TERMS OF THIS
INDIVIDUAL AND HIS INFLUENCE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THE DAVIDIANS
WILL SAY, SOME OF THEM WILL SAY,
WELL, IF THIS WAS WHAT HE SAW AS
THE WILL OF GOD, AND IT WAS TIME
TO HAVE THESE CHILDREN BORN, WHO
BETTER TO DO THAT THAN THE
MESSIAH OR REPRESENTATIVE OF
GOD?
THEY HAVE THEIR RATIONALE.
MOST OUTSIDERS WOULD PRETTY
SEVERELY QUESTION THAT.
>> INDIVIDUALS INSIDE THE BRANCH
DAVIDIAN COMPOUND, WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF PLACING TEARGAS INTO
THE BUILDING.
EXIT THE COMPOUND NOW.
SUBMIT TO THE PROPER AUTHORITY,
DAVID.
>> DURING THE SIEGE, THE FBI
CAME TO ME, AND THEY ASKED ME IF
I KNEW KARESH.
AND I TOLD THEM, YES, I DID.
I TOLD THEM, I CAN GO IN THERE
AND DIFFUSE THE SITUATION.
I CAN TELL I'M HE'S BROUGHT THE
ATTENTION OF THE WORLD.
HE'S DONE WHAT HE WAS CALLED TO
DO.
.
COME OUT.
HE WOULD BE BETTER OUT -- BETTER
OFF TO COME OUT ALIVE AND TEACH
THE TRUTH THAN COME OUT DEAD,
BUT THE PROPHECY SAID HE WOULD
DIE.
THEY SAID, NO, WE CAN'T LET YOU
GO THERE.
I SAID, OK.
>> MADAM ATTORNEY GENERAL, I AM
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED IN THE
DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
, THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION, THE AGENCY OF
ALCOHOL, TOBACCO, AND FIREARMS.
WHEN IN GOD'S NAME IS THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
GOING TO UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
ARE VERY SENSITIVE EVENTS THAT
YOU CAN'T PUT BARBED WIRE, GUNS,
FBI, SECRET SERVICE AROUND THEM,
SENDING IN SOUND 24 HOURS A DAY,
AND THEN WONDER WHY THEY DO
SOMETHING UNSTABLE?
>> NOTHING WE DO NOW CAN CHANGE
THE SUFFERING FELT BY THE
FAMILIES OF THE ATF AGENTS OR
THE FAMILIES OF THOSE WHO
PERISHED IN THE COMPOUND.
WE MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
LEARN FROM THESE EVENTS ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO IN THE FUTURE TO
PREVENT PEOPLE LIKE DAVID KORESH
OR PEOPLE MOTIVATED BY OTHER
THOUGHTS FROM CAUSING SUCH A
SENSELESS, HORRIBLE LOSS OF
HUMAN LIFE.
>> I THINK THAT THIS WAS A
LEARNING EXPERIENCE, AS WELL.
WE HAVE TAKEN CARE IN HANDLING
LITTLE GROUPS SINCE THAT TIME,
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT BOTH SIDES
HAVE LEARNED SOMETHING FROM ALL
OF THAT.
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT WE
SHOULD MAKE NO LAWS ESTABLISHING
RELIGION, NOR PROHIBITING THE
FREE EXERCISE OF RELIGION.
LITTLE GROUPS THAT WANT TO
EXERCISE THIS FREEDOM TO PURSUE
THEIR UNDERSTANDING AND THEIR
LIVING OUT OF CHRISTIANITY AS
THEY FEEL APPROPRIATE -- I THINK
GENERALLY THE NATION HAS
SUPPORTED THAT.
IT IS WHEN YOU MOVE FROM YOUR
BELIEVE SYSTEM INTO SOME
PRACTICES THAT ARE SEEN TO BE
DANGEROUS TO OTHERS OR HARMFUL
IN SOME WAY THAT YOU MIGHT
EXPECT GOVERNMENT INTERVENTION.